it is a monday morning alex good to see
you good to see you too and good to see
you monica happy monday
hey and happy monday to you guys as well
thank you so much y'all have a good
weekend
yes you know what i'm so pumped up it
was so nice to hear about all the
casinos starting to open and go back to
24 7 operations so
all the family and friends are calling
i'm like nope can't come yet
no no but soon soon
soon absolutely all right guys hey it is
6 40 right now it is the last week of
february of course black history month
we're closing it out and i couldn't
think of a better way to do it than with
this hip hop powerhouse
ladies and gentlemen this is tony
blackman she is the first
hip-hop ambassador to travel with the
u.s department of state
she also makes hip-hop meditation music
and she is an author
her book is coming out wisdom of the
cipher it's coming out this spring and
she is joining us
this morning tony blackman how are you
i'm good sending you love from brooklyn
hey
i love new yorkers thank you so much for
being here with us tony i
i was telling uh the audience that you
know your resume is just a little too
long for me to read it's like
ladies and gentlemen not even kidding
it's two pages long you have shared the
stage
with most deaf the roots wu-tang clan
sarah mclaughlin sheryl crow charlie
hunter
quartet just to name a few first of all
tell us who the heck you are and what
this hip-hop thing is all about with the
government that's amazing
i'm tony blackman i am an artist and
social entrepreneur
i'm the first cultural ambassador for
hip-hop the first hip-hop
envoy i first traveled as an american
cultural specialist
in a program that is now uh defunct but
i still work with the u.s department of
state
um in a variety of ways and especially
through a program through next level
and we actually have a special um
program coming up
i'll be working with ywanday austin and
the artist moomoo fresh
uh we're working in the congo for
women's month virtually
very good i love that now tell us a
little bit more about your travels and
what you've experienced because again
you've
you've hung out with some pretty big
names out there and you're very humble
about it when i was talking to you on
the phone but
your job is a pretty big job well you
know
um my work was the foundation for a
comprehensive
hip-hop diplomacy program um by the u.s
department of state
and i was a sort of a guinea guinea pig
if you
if you will and now there are hundreds
of artists
who have been able to where where we
where we where we
are
okay i think we might be having some
audio issues tony are you still there
i am here okay all right well let's move
on to the next one
i got you now okay so do you teach
hip-hop because if i'm an instructor or
a teacher or
you know a college professor right now
there are courses i mean i even think
jay-z teaches a course in hip-hop talk
about that part of it and do you go
around speaking to classes of you know
aspiring hip-hop artists yeah i work as
a matter of fact i do a lot of speaking
i'm going to speak be speaking at beloit
college uh
march 17th um and a couple other schools
in april and i do talks i do lectures i
do workshops i also teach master classes
where i work with
artists who are in training i teach
freestyling is my specialty i am an
advocate
of improvisation and impromptu speaking
and freestyle rap and performance so
yeah i work with schools for my whole
life i'm a pioneer
in hip-hop education hip-hop theater and
hip-hop diplomacy of course
and um i think it's a really really
important thing for
teachers not only music educators but
teachers in other subject areas to
really explore
hip-hop as a tool for um being able to
impact the lives of their students
yeah because it hasn't only crossed
cultures it's across genres in music i
mean you got people in
asia rapping people in africa rapping
and hip-hop has some deep roots
okay before we close out give us a
little bit of what you do i know you're
good at improvisation
oh you want a freestyle i want a
freestyle yeah
oh here i am with monica on a monday
it'd be tony blackman and i'm
freestyling this way from the east coast
from brooklyn to vegas
i'm telling you said in hip-hop i do
trust because
music has a power of its own and we've
got to do it pull it out into it
full-grown even when we get older
we can get bolder and it'll take the
weight off of your shoulders
so that you can relax ah so that you'll
be able to just kick back
um monica monday
rock this way thank you tony
okay okay okay guys you ready for this
i'm i'm a rapper too
i'm gonna i'm gonna i mean this is ode
to sugar heel gang you ready
yes okay or with a hip hop inhibitive
inhibitor hip hip for hopping you don't
stop the rock until the bang bang boogie
say up jump the booger to the rhythm of
the boogie to be
and now what you hear is not a test i'm
rapping to the beat
and me the crew and my friends were
gonna try to move your feet okay i gotta
stop cause i'm getting the wrap now so
can i travel with you next time tony
yes you can join i have a collective
called rhyme like a girl yeah um what
he's based in uh in vegas she's a math
and science teacher fourth grade but
she's a mental lyricist
so we can we can get it going we're
gonna get together and get our group
going vegas is the perfect place and now
that we're starting to come back online
we're gonna hit the road okay
yes all right tony how can folks get in
touch with you because like i said i
think what you have to teach what you
have to offer
a lot of uh you know young hip-hop
artists and people in music in general
could use your skills
well they can find me i'm on social
media everywhere from
um instagram twitter and tick tock uh
tony blackman that's also where you can
find my hip hop meditation content
series
i do a lot of patient music guided
meditation
button aesthetic and my website
tonyblackman.com
all right a pleasure chatting with you
thank you so much for being here i
appreciate that hey folks and don't
forget you can watch the replay yeah
i'll be rapping again on the moj show
facebook live
weeknights at 7 pm so please check it
out i appreciate that so
okay sherry you got any wrapping you
what can you do
nothing well first of all you're gonna
have to teach me monica because the
producers tell me to rap
all the time i never bust out a move
like that it's always
they're telling me to speed up